eins muss man corona lassen das virus
haucht der alten tante eu plötzlich
neues leben ein
750 milliarden schwerer wiederaufbau
fonds soll unserem kontinent aus der
krise helfen
und zum ersten mal überhaupt macht
europa da für gemeinsame schulden ist
eine sensation
diese woche verkündet von ursula von der
leyen rücke ein historischer moment und
da zahlt es sich natürlich aus dass die
englisch beherrscht und pathos pop star
resources mayo eis produziert has become
an economic crisis that you can ziert
from sie weltraum ja wirklich ein
meilenstein
wenn es denn dazu kommt oder es müssen
ja alle 27 parlament in europa zustimmen
250 milliarden als kredit und dann packt
sie noch 500 milliarden als zuschuss
oben drauf ich muss bekloppt sagen mein
chef bringt mich um eben nicht eben
nicht die chefin angela merkel hat sich
das mit den zuschüssen ja ausgedacht
endlich haben sie es begriffen nach all
den jahren dass es nichts hilft hoch
verschuldeten ländern wie italien noch
mehr schulden obendrauf zu kübeln wann
sollen die das wie zurück zeit die ganze
kohle wird dann aus dem eu-haushalt
abgestottert bis ins jahr 2058 dann bin
ich süße 92 bestes zdf alter auf den
letzten metern ihrer kanzlerschaft trägt
die merkel plötzlich spendierhosen anzug
deshalb wollen wir einen zeitlich
befristeten fonds auflegen im umfang von
500 milliarden euro plus die nationalen
maßnahmen von etwa 2 billionen plus
einen haushalt für sieben jahre der auch
noch einmal ungefähr eine million
umfassen wird plus die europäische
antwort das macht 3 millionen chf sich
sowas von zu mit meinem geld besser ist
das ja denn in diesen tagen entscheidet
sich ob die eu gestärkt aus corona
hervorgeht oder auseinanderfliegt im
schlimmsten fall
außerdem feiert ein dreamteam sein
comeback merck co klingt besser als
makrelen jahre lang hat angela
sämtlicher europa ideen von im manual
ungelesen in den schredder geworfen und
jetzt auf einmal ist das alte knistern
zurück
kino im zdf die geschichte einer frau im
herbst ihrer kanzlerschaft wegen corona
krieg die patente angela seit monaten
keinen besuch in ihrer berliner doppel
auch selbst
es bleiben nur erinnerungen an die
manuelle ihre jugendliebe als ob er in
paris
jahrzehnte später das überraschende
wiedersehen bei einer zoom
videokonferenz- und sofort hat es zoom
gemacht eine alte liebe flammt online
wieder auf in endlosen romantischen
chats denken sie über gemeinsame
schulden nach und wollen sogar ein kind
aus österreich adoptieren nach einem
roman von inga livestream mit jeder
glasfaser meines körpers ein wirklich
schlimmer film
[Musik]
in ihrem zdf wo die romantik ein zuhause
hat ja hoffentlich schafft es die eu
diesmal den alten euro geburtsfehler zu
korrigieren gemeinsame währung ohne
gemeinsame wirtschaftspolitik
funktioniert halt nicht vor allem wenn
die lebensverhältnisse immer
unterschiedlicher werden und wenn man
sieht was aktuell so zwischen china und
den usa ab geht als beispiel ist ein
starkes europa doch geradezu
überlebenswichtig
trotzdem gibt es natürlich auch
widerstand gegen merkels plan österreich
schweden dänemark und die niederlande
die sogenannte gruppe der sparsam und
vier die sich selbst als die sparsam
vier bezeichnen die sparsamen vier die
sparsamen vierten sparsamen 4 mit seinen
sparsamen freundin frechere vier die
geizigen 4
ja das trifft schon eher die freakigen
44 glorreiche spannungen von den machern
von spar night express und natürlich
spamer get on board spiele die wir uns
wirklich hätten sparen sollen zu spät
übrigens vor kroner und unter abzug der
zinszahlung für altschulden
erwirtschaften italien griechenland und
portugal höhere überschüsse im
staatshaushalt als die sparsamen 4
österreich hat es seit einführung des
euro in keinem jahr geschafft die
maastricht kriterien zur
staatsverschuldung einzuhalten ja aber
man kann ja trotzdem nur große fresse
haben wir wollen keine schuldenunion und
auch keinen einstieg in eine
schuldenunion durch die hintertür
der niederländische finanzminister wuchs
traf hatte die frage aufgeworfen warum
die südlichen eu-länder nichts aus der
finanzkrise 2009 gelernt haben und
weiterhin hoch verschuldet sind ja
komisch warum lernen die dann nichts
dazu diese doofen italiener was redet
der mann da die niederlande sein land
sanieren sich seit jahren auf kosten des
restlichen europas mit ihren asozialen
steuersparmodellen ja ich sag mal
italienische konzerne wie fiat haben
ihren firmensitz ja nicht in holland
weil es da so schön ist wirklich mehr
als 84 prozent der einnahmen die italien
aufgrund von steueroasen verliert
fließen in andere europäische länder wie
die niederlande und genau wie die
holländer sind auch wir deutschen voll
stolz auf unseren exportüberschuss
der funktioniert aber nur weil andere
sich für unsere produkte verschulden ich
sage ware europäer unterstützen gerade
jetzt in der not die deutsche
exportindustrie auch privat ja liebe
italiener zur hochzeit nicht immer nur
doofe toaster schenken warum nicht mal
die getriebelosen 6 megawatt
windturbinen von siemens oder die
beliebte horizontal akzenta schnecken
puppe von stall kam dolles ding nicht
immer nur schultypen zur einschulung
spanische kinder freuen sich doch viel
mehr über eine speedmaster xl 145 offset
druckmaschine des weltmarktführers
heidelberg wie sagt man zum griechischen
muttertag schöner ich liebe dich mama
als mit einer duften rolltreppe von
thyssenkrupp also lieber costas lieber
mario lieber pablo werdet jetzt brd
prime kunden und bestellt deutsche
maschinen versandkostenfrei
die ersten 100 kriegen 3 prozent rabatt
auf einen claas lexion 8900 mähdrescher
aus harsewinkel
das dürfen wir nie vergessen südeuropäer
sind vielmehr als menschen das sind
kunden ja unsere kunden kauft mal
genauso weiter leuten dann fahren wir
auch bald wieder bei euch in den urlaub
die reisewarnung für eu-länder soll ja
angeblich bald aufgehoben werden wenn es
klappt obwohl nach diesem beitrag hier
habe ich eigentlich jetzt schon keinen
bock mehr
wer sich jetzt auf tomatensaft gefreut
hat der wird enttäuscht
der wird nämlich nicht mehr ausgeschenkt
stattdessen gibt es nun ein stilles
wasser aus der flasche wasser 2020 was
für ein scheiß ja olaf schubert unser
heute-show reiseexperte reden wir mal
urlaub über urlaub mit abstand und
hygieneregeln
wir sind schon mal als kleiner
vorgeschmack auf den sommer ein paar
aktuelle bilder vom letzten wochenende
aus holland und ja mit bloßem auge
schwer zu erkennen ich meine das sind
nicht überall ein meter fünfzig oder wie
will man abstandsregeln am strand
wirklich durchsetzen schwer
die menschen sollen sich ja wohlfühlen
man kann da glaube ich nur sanft
regulieren mit berittener polizei mit
kampfhunden oder elektroschocks aber im
großen und ganzen bleibt das problem wir
in deutschland haben einfach zu wenig
strand ja und man hat sich ja seit ende
des zweiten weltkriegs überhaupt nicht
im geringsten bemüht damals neue strände
zu erschließen
ja und jetzt muss man natürlich die
wenigen strände besser nutzen zeitlich
intensivieren also da sich die einen
eben am tag sollen und die anderen
nachts und ich würde vor allem alle
strände automatisch zu fkk stränden
erklären also wenn einem da einmal wie
du könnte ein signal kommt erhält man ja
automatisch abstand ja und es gibt
natürlich jede menge tolle pfiffige
ideen
wir haben die bilder mal vorbereitet zum
beispiel diese brutkästen ja also wenn
das glas jetzt auch noch so ein kleines
bisschen linsen funktion hat dann genügt
ja wenn man dort drei minuten darunter
liegt dann hast du solche brandflecken
und die kannst du dann geschickt am
körper verreiben und das tolle ist diese
kisten sind auch abschließbar also
bestens geeignet zur kinderbetreuung und
dann gibt sie auch noch mit
milchglasscheibe also wenn der säugling
noch
werden muss perfekt und man kann die
kinder nicht mehr sehen also mehr kann
man sich als partie gar nicht wünschen
absolut was komplett wegfällt ist
dagegen das gedrängel am hotel buffet
das ist ja muss man sagen für viele
deutsche so was wie das highlight einer
darauf freut man sich dieses archaische
gefühl für seine familie die letzten
fünf kilo shrimps zu jagen also der
direkte nahkampf mit einer touristen
auch um liegen am pool fällt komplett
weg wie will man das kompensieren schwer
also da bricht wirklich ganz viel aktive
erholung weg man versucht es jetzt zu
simulieren es gibt jetzt ein
computerspiel call auf frühstücksbuffet
und das hat jetzt bei jugendlichen
wirklich schon kultstatus weil es ist
wirklich ultra brutal sehr verstörend
man sieht doch ziemlich original wii
sowie die touristen miteinander kämpfen
wie die sich so schokocreme ins gesicht
schmieren wie die sie mit einem
kaffeelöffel die die augen ausstechen
also absolut hatte stoffen richtig ist
killergames aber das signal kann es
natürlich nicht ersetzen
na ja es wird einfach es wird alles
anders und das fängt ja schon bei der
anreise an die luftfahrt lobby hat noch
nicht durchgesetzt dass der mittelplatz
im flieger eben doch besetzt werden darf
und wie aktuelle studien aus den usa
zeigen braucht nur einer zu müssen und
dann hängt die wolke rosa wolke für 34
minuten über deine reihe lüftung hin
oder her redest du noch zu flugreisen
und wie verhalte ich mich im flieger
richtig für mich muss sagen also ich
finde diesen ganzen öffentlichen
flugverkehr seit jahren wahnsinn so und
ich halte mich da auch seit jahren raus
also ich habe ein eigenes flugzeug und
das ist natürlich in aller hinsicht
besser also ich weiß ja noch also also
dieser kontakt schon ohne corona das war
ja wenn wenn alle auf gestalten sind
dann das gepäck rausholen wenn wenn wenn
es dann da leib an die
fleischfachverkäuferin abtreibt weiß
noch genau wie das war
ich habe meine freundin sowie kennen
gelernt und heute wo sollen die erosion
ja also wenn wir dann liegt das bonbon
der kriegt er die die erosionen nicht
mehr zum einatmen
mit dem ellbogen gleich ein geschmiedet
in die visage also vernünftig sein
selber flugzeug kaufen
viele machen jetzt natürlich aus purer
not urlaub in deutschland
was wären da deine empfehlung wohin und
was macht man da also deutschland ist
als reiseland bei mir ziemlich weit oben
also gleich auf dem zweiten platz nach
nordkorea
und es gibt ja viel in deutschland zu
entdecken die natur ist wieder auf dem
vormarsch nicht nur der wolf also auch
der borkenkäfer ist wieder da es gibt
viel zu entdecken und preislich ist es
natürlich auch wesentlich interessanter
als jetzt sagen tropez oder oder monaco
oder kauft sie dort eine kugel eis da
wollen die fünf euro als deutscher denke
sie gleich auf die waffe gibt fand und
das einzige ich sag mal ja urlaub in
deutschland es ist jetzt nicht so
exotisch ist so ein bisschen sexy sag
ich mal so wie mit der band low end an
gas also im endeffekt ich bin nicht
dafür 89 auf die straße gegangen um
jetzt urlaub zu machen
in döbeln das verstehe ich olaf schubert
[Applaus]
und und alle sobald wir eine millionen
abonnenten haben liebe liebe liebe fans
ich würde mich so was schon freuen wenn
ihr ein abo damals brauchte er würde den
gern mag so ist unglücklich macht